can you tell us the opening line of
longfellows Paul Revere poem you know
actually I can't i have never memorized
that poem well and that's a sign of a
slipping American educational system it
really is and that's exactly why my book
is so needed hi I'm Nicolas be with
reason TV today we're talking with Joel
Miller author of the revolutionary Paul
Revere Joel thanks for talking thanks
for having me here you know tour on the
back cover he's famous for his ride he's
essential for so much more what is Paul
Revere's significance to contemporary
America I think there are several
elements of his significance for certain
one of them is his role as an
entrepreneur and as a commercial
visionary starting from the time he was
a young man working in his father's
silver shop inherited his father's
silver shop all the way until his death
in 1818 he was involved in commercial
endeavours and always seeking to advance
himself and his family I mean I see the
a version of Ben Franklin and
entrepreneur who's also deeply enmeshed
in politics yes but at a much different
level Franklin was an intellectual
Revere was a blue-collar guy who was
involved in the political clubs of
Boston but not at the level that someone
like Franklin was in Pennsylvania talk a
little bit about the ride and you know
both how that took place and you know
what's the big myth of the ride but then
also how you know how'd it is Revere the
everyman in in revolutionary America or
that's I guess a string of questions
I'll work on them one by one okay as far
as the myth of the ride there's a lot of
myths around the ride the reason for
that in part is that the cigna the the
point at which it became significant in
the American story came about so much
later after it happened in almost 100
years in fact when Longfellow wrote the
poem and so there was an awful lot of
encrusted stuff in that story and in
that telling and an awful lot of things
that were
that in that too only and just some flat
out errors for instance Revere was not
standing in Charlestown waiting to see
the two lights you know the old north
church yeah he hung or he had someone
hang those lights but they weren't for
him he knew for sure what was going on
he was enroute to Charlestown to get on
a horse and do the ride so that's one
element that's just completely mythic
and the other I think several other
historians have talked about this
already but the simple fact that he
wasn't you know alone there was of
course William Dawes there were other
writers as well in fact the the moment
the word began getting out it started
going everywhere immediately there's
just this sort of disorganized rush to
to get the word out and and that was
definitely something that you don't get
out of the you know the old story now
this is not your first book what drew
you to this material or don't reveal the
first book i did was about drugs and the
second book i did was about the size of
government and in reality Revere story
overlaps strangely pretty much 141 yeah
you know smuggling turns out to be a
huge story and the founding of our
country the tax laws and the regulations
the Navigation Acts they were called
that governed commerce and uniting the
colonies were floated by smugglers and
not just you know ragtag guys rich
gentle Brook smuggled and including
Revere uh well he is the people in his
circle definitely he actually did do
some smuggling after the Revolution in
fact against the government he helped
create yes there were tools that he
wanted and needed and there was a law
banning trade with England more tools
and so he just had them brought over
anyway right so it's like ordering from
amazon UK or so pretty much yeah so that
was one element that i was i knew a
little bit about because as I had was
studying the the drug war
the Fourth Amendment stuff came up and
that obviously leads to the writs of
assistance and as you start studying the
writs of assistance you start finding
out about all this smuggling go run and
that story I tried to play up and really
give a context for in them in the
revolution in the book that really blew
my mind the other thing was just the
frustrations faced by the Bostonians in
particular it was felt all up and down
the colonies but the frustration they
felt in not having a voice in power that
would pay attention to their concerns
and so the encroachments of the
government were were objected to but
they had no voice in objecting and so I
think I say in the in the book at one
point that they you know may have been
eloquent but the you know the ears back
in London were made out of wood and no
one paid any in which you know now we're
in a political season where you know
there's a movement called the Tea Party
movement people are saying you know
government is not listening to us how do
you translate what Revere is about you
know into contemporary America and what
do you do about the violence I mean you
know Revere and other colonial
revolutionaries were all about you know
violence in the end I mean how you know
how did how does this play out in the
contemporary drama well I'll answer part
of the question and I'll take a dodge on
the second part the the first part of
the question would be that there is an
awful lot of corollaries between people
today frustrated with government and the
violence that came out of that time was
all about frustration there you go back
in English history you'll find uprising
after uprising about taxes and so on so
what happened in the American Revolution
was not rare in fact it was something
that was you know a repeatable deal in
the in the history of England so it
wasn't at some level of surprised at all
that it ended up happening the
frustrating thing for us today is we've
been at peace for so long when people
start yelling at each other people get
scared and people get
you know worried and so on obviously no
one wants to see the violence on the
level that happened in the days of
revere ware full riots happened and down
streets and homes were torn down and
things like that but the frustration is
real and I think that I boobs people to
pay attention of frustrated people
especially when they have reasonable
reasonable grievances right talk a bit
about Nelson Thomas Nelson publishers
who you work with and who published this
book and also their current imprint well
Thomas Nelson is a publisher that's been
around since 1798 it was started by
Thomas Nelson back in Scotland and he
basically decided that he wanted to
figure out ways of making classics
affordable for people so he figured out
ways of reducing costs and printing and
someone in fact he developed a printing
press that was able to increase
efficiencies and printing dramatic this
was at a time when a book could cost
somebody's years wages right yeah how
many books were very expensive so these
were like books for the common grand
kind of thing through you know ups and
downs and so on for years and years the
company existed and at some point in the
1960s was purchased by an American
immigrant named Sam Moore they at least
the American interest in the business
and that's the Thomas Nelson that I work
for based in Nashville Tennessee
conservative probably for the most part
and its outlook and so it was natural at
some point to start an imprint that
would focus on political books Nelson is
mostly known for religious titles and
Bible publishing but we've done books
Bill Bennett's history books we've done
and judge napolitano new book in fact
all his books we've done right so it
fits in at Nelson in that were concerned
about justice and concerned about the
encroachments of the state and we're
also concerned about telling good
stories and so do you find from a
publishing point of view is is this you
know book publishing is one of those
industries that's always in kind of
current
a decline it seems but the longest dying
industry yeah you know next and i'll
even longer than Broadway right now and
it's the i mean is do you feel empowered
by you know whether it's amazon or the
internet or distribution channels i mean
is this a good time to be from an
alternative power center not to be in
New York or DC or LA or something like
that to be in a place like Nashville
Nashville is an interesting cultural
place and I think there are a lot of
strengths to that so I would say yes I
also think that the digital publishing
creates a tremendous number of
opportunities obviously like any time of
upheaval the trick is to stay on the
part that's not falling down and you
know we're constantly experimenting with
things to try to do that but I think
it's a pretty fun time to be in
publishing no can you tell us the
opening line of longfellows Paul Revere
poem you know actually i can't i have
never memorized that poem well and
that's a sign of a slipping American
educational system it really is and
that's exactly why my book is so needed
well I want to thank you joel for
talking to us for recent TV i'm nick
gillespie we've been talking with joel
miller author of the revolutionary Paul
Revere